detrás de un estado de emergencia
denuncias de abusos el observatorio
universitario de Derechos Humanos del
Salvador publicó un informe sobre
violaciones ocurridas entre el 27 de
marzo y el 4 de julio titulado 100 días
de régimen de excepción en El Salvador
tiene denuncias como la siguiente el
observatorio identificado
la pregunta de torturas el informe
también denuncia la muerte de 59
detenidos bajo custodia Estatal y un
hacinamiento del
247,6% en las cárceles en junio amnistía
internacional denunció violaciones
masivas de derechos humanos Esto en la
guerra contra las pandillas del
presidente nayib bukele pero los
pandilleros son tontos porque lo que
hemos estado hablando No es que vamos a
retroceder sino que ni siquiera vamos a
mantenernos igual sino que vamos a
reciar esta guerra contra las pandillas
las protestas de familiares de detenidos
se suceden estas son imágenes del martes
en San Salvador denuncian ser Víctimas
de arrestos arbitrarios y no entendemos
el Por qué pasa el tiempo el Por qué
pasa pasan los días y no salen libertad
el 26 de Marzo hubo 62 asesinatos en El
Salvador el presidente nayib bukele
culpó a las pandillas y la asamblea votó
el estado de excepción
ya se ha prorrogado en cuatro ocasiones
desde entonces ha habido cerca de 50.000
detenidos